No tak.
Quantum circuit będzie jednostką wartości
dla twojego biznesu, qubit jest jednostką informacji,
a circuit jest jednostką obliczeń.
Spróbujmy więc zrozumieć, czym jest quantum circuit
i przyjrzyjmy się jego budowie.
Tak wygląda quantum circuit.
Składa się z elementów — qubit-y
są przedstawiane jako poziome linie; w tym przypadku pokazujemy
circuit, który ma cztery qubit-y, jak widzisz
tutaj. Gate-y to
sposób, w jaki kontrolujemy qubit-y,
a gate-y czytamy od lewej do prawej.
Gate-y na pojedynczym qubit-cie mogą być
gate-ami jednoqbitowymi lub wieloqbitowymi.
Widzisz tam controlled gate —
to ten, który ma linię między dwoma qubit-ami,
i tam właśnie będzie zachodzić operacja splątania.
Na końcu masz pomiar i klasyczne wyjście.
Co bardzo ważne — circuit uruchamiasz wiele razy,
żeby uzyskać wynik — to pojęcie shot-ów.
Licznik shot-ów to liczba razy,
ile musisz powtórzyć obliczenie, żeby dostać wynik.
No dobra,
jak one wyglądają?
Zobaczmy, jak wygląda dwubitowy — coś w stylu
tego obrazka, który pokazałem wcześniej — wprowadzamy zmianę fazy,
i pokazałem wcześniej operację, która wykonuje ten obrót,
umożliwiający tę operację interferencji.
Porównajmy więc klasyczny circuit
z quantum circuit. W klasycznym circuit
nie zobaczysz niebieskich obszarów,
nie ma obrotów, wszystko jest różowe,
i masz te pojedyncze stany.
W tych gate-ach widzimy okna stanu,
ale zwróć uwagę, jak inaczej będzie wyglądał
quantum circuit, gdy go faktycznie zaimplementujemy.
To są rzeczywiste circuit-y, które uruchamiamy na naszych komputerach kwantowych —
możesz sam je wypróbować.
Circuit-y, które będziemy tworzyć,
z kombinacją gate-ów,
generują pełny, złożony obraz amplitudy,
który wam pokazałem.
Dlaczego to ważne? Ponieważ
możemy teraz generować te złożone relacje
między qubit-ami pod względem faz
i splątania, a następnie poprzez akt pomiaru
jesteśmy w stanie zkolapsować tę ogromną ilość
obliczeń, które zachodzą w środku, do
jakiejś ważnej odpowiedzi.
I tak w końcu dochodzimy
do odpowiedzi. Zestawiając je wizualnie obok siebie,
możesz poczuć, że klasyczny circuit nigdy
nie jest w stanie wykorzystać rozległej przestrzeni obliczeniowej,
którą może wykorzystać quantum circuit.
To daje ci intuicję co do bogactwa,
z jakim możemy uzyskać dostęp do tej dużej przestrzeni stanów.
Piękne w tym jest to, że możemy
mieć wiele klas circuit-ów, które
pełnią różne funkcje.
Na przykład oto circuit,
który jest zaprojektowany do modelowania ryzyka finansowego.
Oto przykład circuit-a
używanego do wyszukiwania i optymalizacji.
A tutaj przykład circuit-a, który służy do
symulacji cząsteczki. Ważna
wskazówka: możesz projektować różne circuit-y
do różnych zastosowań.
Circuit-y, które projektujemy, są następnie uchwycone
w oprogramowaniu i przechowywane jako oprogramowanie.
W naszym przypadku trzymamy je w Qiskit,
czyli w naszym open-source'owym zestawie narzędzi do obliczeń kwantowych.
To jedno z najszerzej używanych
frameworków oprogramowania do obliczeń kwantowych.
Możesz sobie wyobrazić budowanie
bibliotek circuit-ów, które są osadzane w
klasycznych programach łączących to, co najlepsze w klasycznym programowaniu,
z tym, co najlepsze w mocy obliczeń kwantowych.